Ich habe keine Lust zu reden, normalerweise, aber mein Mann hat mich mitgebracht, deswegen bin ich hier.
Okay. Sie denken, Sie haben keine Probleme oder keine Beschwerden?
Ja, ich bin ganz normal denke ich, aber mein Mann hat mir Gezwungen zu kranken, zu kommen. Ich weiß nicht warum. Ich habe keine Lust zu reden.
Okay. Ihren Wunsch ist sehr wichtig für uns. Sie sagen, Sie haben keine Probleme oder Beschwerden. Ich kann nicht etwas machen.
Aber so etwas möchte ich. Darf ich Sie um Ihren Namen bitten?
Ja, mein Name ist Kröger.
Kröger, das ist Frau oder Frau?
Frau, ja, ich bin Frau.
Ja, Frau Kröger, möchten Sie Ihren Vornamen bestimmen?
Mein Nachname ist Kröger.
Ja, könnten Sie oder möchten Sie Ihren Nachname bestimmen?
Ja, K-R-Ö-G-E-R, mein Nachname ist Kröger.
Kröger, was machen Sie zu Hause? Arbeiten Sie?
Ja, Frau Doktor, ich arbeite.
Was machen Sie wirklich?
Ich arbeite als Beamter im Rathaus.
Ja, sehr gut.
Nein, das ist nicht gut. Meine Arbeit ist sehr stressig. Ich möchte nicht zur Arbeit gehen.
Okay, ich habe eine Frage. Warum denkt Ihr Mann, brauchen Sie Hilfe?
Ich weiß nicht. Wir haben Probleme zu Hause.
Er sagt immer, dass ich Probleme habe. Ich schlafe immer und mache keinen Haushalt.
Ich möchte nicht kochen und ich möchte nicht zu Hause putzen und Kinder zu kümmern. Alles kommt mir zu viel.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Art-R-Plus?
Ich weiß nicht, aber seit vielleicht 4 oder 5 Monaten.
4 oder 5 Monate. Denken Sie, gibt es eine bestimmte Auslöser?
Was kann eine Auslöser sein, Frau Doktor?
Wir streiten immer mit meinem Mann. Alles kommt mir zu viel.
Ich habe meine Tochter verloren vor 5 Monaten. Ich möchte nicht zur Arbeit gehen. Ich möchte immer schlafen.
Das ist normal, denke ich. Ich möchte schlafen und nicht zur Arbeit gehen. Ist das nicht normal?
Darf ich Sie fragen, wie ist Ihre Tochter verstorben?
Wegen einem Fahrradunfall.
Es tut mir sehr leid, zu hören.
Fühlen Sie sich in letzter Zeit traurig, müde und antreiblos?
Ja, natürlich, Frau Doktor. Ich habe meine Tochter verloren.
Das ist normal für mich. Ich möchte nicht sehen. Ich möchte meine Freunde und Freunde nicht treffen.
Ich möchte schlafen und nichts machen.
Okay, verstehe. Das ist eine sehr schwierige Situation. Das muss sehr schwer für Sie sein.
Aber Sie müssen Ihr Leben weitergehen. Oder? Haben Sie andere Kinder?
Ich habe einen anderen Sohn. Er ist 7 Jahre alt.
Sie müssen Ihr Leben weitergehen. Er braucht Sie natürlich.
Ich habe mir vieles in die Hände genommen. Alles kommt zu viel für mich.
Aber bitte geben Sie nicht auf. Sie müssen für Ihren Sohn stark sein.
Ihre Reaktion ist vollkommen verständlich. Aber ich glaube, Schritt bei Schritt wird es besser.
Ich habe keine Hoffnung, Frau Doktor.
Entschuldigen Sie die Frage. Aber haben Sie schon mal darüber nachgedacht, sich das Leben zu nehmen?
Ja, ich habe vielmals gedacht. Vielmals habe ich gedacht, aber ich habe keine Macht, mein Leben zu nehmen.
Haben Sie Plane oder Vorbereitungen getroffen?
Ich kann nicht vorbereiten. Ich habe keine Macht, mich zu vorbereiten. Aber ich habe vielmals gedacht, mein Leben zu nehmen.
Mein Leben kommt mir unnötig.
Haben Sie schon mal darüber nachgedacht, eine Therapie zu machen?
Nein, meine Freundin ist auch Psychotherapeutin. Sie hat einmal mit mir gesprochen. Aber ich finde diese Gespräche unnötig.
Aber ich sehe, Sie haben eine Unterstützung von der Familie. Ihr Mann kann Unterstützung.
Mein Mann kümmert sich um meinen Sohn. Sie kaufen im Supermarkt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob alles mir zu viel kommt.
Okay, fragt Krega, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 36 Jahre alt.
Sie ist sehr, sehr jungen Frau. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich habe nichts in Nester gemacht. Vor einem Jahr war ich 56.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
1 Meter 68. Ich wiege 62 Kilogramm.
68 und 62.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewöhnlich abgenommen?
Ich weiß nicht Frau Doktor, ich habe nicht gemessen. Aber ich kann meine Hose nicht mehr tragen. Ich denke, ich habe sie eingenommen.
Haben Sie auch Schlafprobleme?
Ich kann nicht schlafen Frau Doktor. Ich treffe in der Bett 3-2 Stunden. Ich fühle mich sehr müde.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Manchmal esse ich viel. Manchmal esse ich nichts. Ich weiß nicht, wie mein Appetit ist. Manchmal habe ich Lust zu essen. Manchmal habe ich keine Lust zu essen.
Haben Sie Nachschweiß?
Nachschweiß? Nein.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Seit 5 Jahren habe ich Verstöpfung.
Ist Ihnen eine chronische Erkrankung bekannt?
Ich leide an Migräne seit 20 Jahren.
Ich war einmal unmächtig geworden. Mein Blutdruck ist immer niedrig. Mein Hausarzt hat mir gesagt, dass mein Blutdruck immer niedrig ist.
Seit wann haben Sie diese 5 Wörter?
Seit 3 Jahren vielleicht.
Noch etwas?
Haben Sie andere Krankheiten?
Ich habe Migräne.
Das alles.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Wenn ich Kopfschmerzen habe, nehme ich Ibuprofen.
Und trinke ich Cola. Cola?
Cola kommt mir gut.
Welche Dosis nehmen Sie?
600 mg.
Rachen Sie pro Krega?
Normalerweise habe ich seit 10 Jahren 5 Zigaretten geraucht. Aber in den letzten 3-4 Monaten brauche ich 1 Schachtel pro Tag.
Okay. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
In Lester trinke ich jeden Tag 1 oder 2 Bier.
Okay. Hatten Sie jemals Kontakt mit Drogen?
Als ich im Gymnasium war, hatte ich eine Joint geraucht.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Nein, Frau Doktor. Ich möchte schlafen. Ich schlafe immer. Ich treibe nicht Sport.
Früher oder vor 2 Monaten, haben Sie regelmäßig Sport getrieben?
Ja. Als ich jung war, habe ich regelmäßig Sport getrieben.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja. Meine Arme waren gebrochen als ich jung war.
Wie bitte? Einmal?
Mein Arm war gebrochen.
Das war der rechte Arm. Deswegen wurde ich operiert.
Okay. Wann war diese Operation?
Als ich jung war. Mit 8 oder 9 Jahren. Ich erinnere mich nicht.
Es gab Platten und Schrauben.
Haben Sie andere Operationen?
Nein.
Okay. Gibt es in Ihrer Familie chronische Erkrankungen?
Meine Mutter hat vor 5 Jahren an Herzinfarkten gelitten.
Okay.
Mein Vater hat selbst Mord mit 58 Jahren.
58. Es tut mir sehr leid.
Okay. Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe eine Schwester.
Okay. Ist sie gesund?
Leider hat sie Brustkrebs seit 2 Jahren. Sie hat viel Schmerzen.
Sie leben in der Nähe. Sie sind sehr eng. Sie haben viel Schmerzen.
Herr Kräger, ich sehe, Sie haben in letzter Zeit viele traurige Dinge erlebt.
Aber ich glaube, Sie können diese Schwierigkeiten gut machen.
Okay.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Ich kann Milch nicht trinken. Wenn ich Milch trinke, habe ich Bauchschmerzen und manchmal Jucken.
Okay. Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, natürlich.
Okay. Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Frau Doktor, letztes Jahr waren wir in Malaga in Spanien mit meinem Sohn. Wir haben sehr gute Zeiten erlebt.
Wenn ich mich erinnere, weine ich immer. Es war ein sehr guter Urlaub. Deswegen weine ich immer. Mein Mann klagte über meine Weihung.
Okay. Das klingt sehr belastend. Ich verstehe, Sie haben in letzter Zeit viele belastende Dinge erlebt.
Und ich bin sehr verzeihlich für Ihre Tochter. Das ist bestimmt nicht einfach, aber sie muss ...
Ich möchte nicht helfen, Frau Doktor. Ich möchte gehen.
Ich bin Frau Kröger.
Frau Kröger, Entschuldigung.
Wir können unser Gespräch hier unterbrechen oder fertig machen.
Aber ich möchte Sie wiederholen.
Ich empfehle Sie, Sie sollten einen anderen Arzt oder Ärztin besprechen.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen psychologischen Vorsitz antworten.
Darf ich jetzt zu Hause gehen? Ich möchte gehen und ich möchte schlafen.
Frau Kröger, ich möchte mit Ihnen und Ihrem Mann sprechen.
Dann können wir entscheiden, ob Sie zu Hause gehen können.
Aber Sie ...
Ich bin Erwachsener. Ich möchte gehen.
Jetzt sollen Sie im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Muss ich über Nacht gehen oder ein paar Stunden?
Ich glaube, Sie müssen im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Dann werde ich Ihre Situation mit meinem Arzt besprechen.
Dann gebe ich Ihnen Bescheid.
Ich warte.
Ich bin nicht draußen. Sie können hier bleiben.
Ich komme gleich zurück.
Okay, Frau Doktor.
Okay, stopp. Bitte stopp.
Ich möchte Ihnen eine kurze Zeit für mich haben.
Ja, bitte schön.
Die Patientin Martina Kröger ist 36 Jahre alt.
Sie ist 1,68 Meter groß und 2,60 Kilogramm schwer.
Frau Kröger stellte sich heute bei uns.
Frau Kröger würde mit Begleitung Ihrem Mann ins Krankenhaus gebracht.
Sie möchte nicht reden.
Sie hat eine depressive Stimmung und Interesseverlust.
Seit wann?
Seit 4 bis 5 Monaten.
Nach dem Tod ist sie aufgetreten.
Sie hatte sich mit der Zeit verschlechtert.
Der Patient hat keine Lust und keinen Kontakt mit Freunden.
Sie hat ihre alltäglichen Aufgaben nicht mehr gemacht.
Sie hat sie nicht mehr erledigt.
Sie arbeitet als Beamte im Rathaus.
Sie berichtete, dass sie viel Stress in der Arbeit hat.
Sie ist verheiratet und ihr Mann immer unter Schutz.
Sie hat Suizidgedanken.
Sie hat sich in der regativen Anamnese angeschränkt.
Sie hat sich in der Abwärtsveränderung verhärtet.
Die Patientin möchte immer schlafen.
Manchmal ist sie mehr, manchmal wenig.
Manchmal ist sie weniger, manchmal mehr.
Sie leidet seit 20 Jahren an Migräne.
Seit 3 Jahren niedriger Blutdruck.
Was ist der Fachbegriff?
Niedriger Blutdruck.
Hypotension.
Er nimmt Hypoprofen.
Was ist der Fachbegriff von Schleffigkeit?
Insomnie.
Insomnie ist ein Schlafproblem.
Ich glaube, das ist Somnolenz.
Er nimmt regelmäßig 600 Hypoprofen.
Bei Bedarf gegen Schleffalgie, gegen Migräne.
Er rauft seit 10 Jahren 5 Zigaretten täglich.
Seit 5 Monaten rauft er 1 Schleffalge pro Tag.
Er trinkt 1-2 Flaschen jeden Tag.
Und Drogenkonsum, die die Patienten berichten,
wenn sie als Jugend einmal joint rauft.
Sie treibt keinen regelmäßigen Sport.
Sie hat Milchunverträglichkeiten.
Sie ist unverträglich.
Sie ist vollständig geübt.
Und Reiseanamnese ist unerfällig.
In der Familienanamnese wurde angegeben,
dass ihr Vater,
im Alter von 58 Jahren, sich selbst unterbricht hat.
Und ihre Mutter hatte vor 5 Jahren einen Myokartinfarkt.
Sie hat eine Schwester.
Sie leidet seit 2 Jahren mit dem Myokartinfarkt.
Die Analysten an der Depressionen
sind nicht mehr in der Situation.
Ich habe keine anderen Differenzdiagnosen.
Meine Diagnose für Akkulärung und Diabechwerden
sollte durchgeführt werden.
Zuerst werde ich Anceti oder MRT des Schadens
veranlassen, Blut abnehmen.
Ich werde die Troidehormone, TSH, TSH, FT3 und FT4 und Elektrolytis.
Warum kontrollieren Sie die Troidehormone?
Um die Hypothroide auszulegen.
Können wir sagen, dass Hypothroide als Differenzdiagnose kommt?
Ja.
Und meine Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, schlage ich die folgende Therapie vor.
Zuerst werde ich diese Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Sie wollen nach Hause gehen.
Sie warten mich im Behandlungszimmer.
Ich möchte diese Situation mit Ihnen besprechen.
Ich darf die Patienten nicht nach Hause gehen.
Warum möchten Sie die Patienten stationär behandeln?
Die Patienten haben Suizidgedanken.
Deshalb möchte ich die Patienten eingeschränkt überwachen.
Ich möchte sie in der Psychiatrie anfordern.
Dann kann ich die notwendigen Medikamente beginnen.
Welche Symptome sprechen für eine Depression bei dieser Patientin?
Diese Patientin hat eine traurige Geschichte.
Sie hat ihre Tochter vor vier Monaten verloren.
Sie hat Suizidgedanken.
Sie hat keine Lust.
Sie hat ungeheuerliche Müdigkeit, Müdigkeit, Fatigue.
Sie hat ungeheuerliche Müdigkeit und Schmerzen.
Sie hat Schlafprobleme, Appetitprobleme.
Sie hat keine Kontakt mit ihrer Familie und ihren Freunden.
Deshalb sprechen diese Symptome für eine Depression.
Hilflosigkeit, Hoffnungslosigkeit,
Abolie, Antriebsstörung, Freudlosigkeit, Wertlosigkeit.
Es gibt viele Symptome bei dieser Patientin.
Sie haben recht.
Was machen Sie zuerst bei dieser Patientin?
Ich möchte die Station aufnehmen.
Wir können körperlich untersuchen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ich beobachte die Allgemeinsysteme.
Ich kontrolliere.
Ich mache eine neurologische Untersuchung.
Ich würde eine neurologische Untersuchung durchführen.
Um Reflexe, um die Reflexe zu bewegen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Hypertriose zu dieser Diagnose kommt.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf,
ob Hautveränderungen in der Haut kommen.
Ich bin nicht so sicher.
Ich achte darauf, ob Hautveränderungen wie kalte oder warme Haut
und trockene oder trockene oder nassere Haut
vorhanden sind.
Ich höre Lungen und Herz ab.
Ich auskultiere Lungen und Herz.
Der Patient kann Tachycardie.
Der Patient hat Tachycardie oder Bratikardie.
Um andere Pathologien oder Hypertroide
oder Hypertroide auszuschließen, muss ich diese Untersuchung durchführen.
Welche operative Diagnostik würden Sie durchführen?
Eine operative Untersuchung kann eine Schadensstelle
durchführen.
Der Patient hat Migräne seit 20 Jahren.
Ich habe nicht gefragt, aber ich glaube,
dass er Kopfschmerzen hat.
Um die möglichen Pathologien auszuschließen,
möchte ich eine Schadensstelle durchführen.
Wie zum Beispiel?
Hirntumor zum Beispiel.
Können Sie bitte die Schadensstelle aufklären?
Ja, ich kann.
Die Schadensstelle ist eine noninvasive Schmerzlosigkeit.
Aber die Strahlung belastet die Untersuchung.
Die Strahlung ist so gering und ungefährlich.
Mit Hilfe der Computer-Tomographie
können wir die Knochenstrukturen,
Frakturen oder Veränderungen an Organen wie Tumoren oder Ergüsse beurteilen.
Der Patient wird richtig positioniert.
Dann machen wir die Untersuchung.
Vor der Untersuchung sollten die Patienten
Metallgengenste und Schmuck ablegen.
Es ist für Schwangere nicht geeignet.
Es sind keine Risikofaktoren.
Es sind weniger Risikofaktoren oder Komplikationen bekannt.
Die Untersuchung dauert etwa 20 oder 30 Minuten.
Eine besondere Vorbereitung ist nicht nötig.
Nach der Untersuchung kann der Patient seinen Alltag ganz normal fortsetzen.
Noch etwas als operative Diagnose?
Was würden Sie bestüren?
MRT oder CT? Noch etwas?
Wie zum Beispiel andere Differentialdiagnosen?
Ich würde eine Sonographie durchführen,
um meine Differentialdiagnosen auszuschließen.
Bei der Sonographie kann ich eine vergrößerte
Troide sehen.
Oder einige Knoten aufstellen.
Nein, feststellen.
Aber in diesem Fall ist die Untersuchung nicht sehr dringend.
Welche Therapiemöglichkeiten kennen Sie?
Ich habe nicht viel Erfahrung mit dieser Therapie.
Deshalb möchte ich eine Psychiatriekonsultation anfordern.
Und eine Psychiatriearztin oder Arztin
kann die Behandlung optimieren.
Aber ich kann empfehlen, eine neue Therapie zu machen.
Aber ich kann empfehlen, eine antidepressive Medikamente anfordern.
Und eine SSRI-Serotonin wieder zu haben.
Bei Schlafstörungen können wir
die Tratsordnungen anordnen.
Psychotherapie ist sehr wichtig.
Entspannungstechniken können wir auch benutzen.
Und hier in Deutschland können wir auch Sonnenlicht, Lichttherapie
für diese Patienten anordnen.
Das ist ein schwieriger Fall.
Gut gemacht.